he will not let it go
you could tell he's latin because land
people are tenacious my name is nick
varela and i'm traveling the country to
sit down with some of the biggest latinx
artists and help tell their story the
ugly question is why aren't land people
succeeding when you come from the
neighborhoods that we come from you need
somebody outside of you to tell you that
you're worthy i'm sure there's somebody
watching who was probably in those shoes
when you were at that time figuring how
am i going to make it out of this job to
start my career
i feel like if you've achieved a certain
amount of success you gotta give back
you can't pretend it's not happening why
do you think not as many people are as
vocal as you are about this subject well
being vocal has its cost when i became
very politically conscious i got a lot
of hate you know go back to your country
go back to mexico which i'm not mexican
but i'll gladly go back to mexico
because it's a great country
caring from one generation to the next
generation i don't want you to go
through what i went through no i don't
want any kid to go through what i went
through how do you maneuver through the
industry i got scars in my head from
hitting that glass ceiling but i
couldn't do it ever much love my stuff
[Music]
you